[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report now presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory along live moods
we got a finals rematch bug sons tonight
but first let's talk trades live lots of
trade action the last few hours the
76ers traded for ben simmons seth curry
andre german and two first round picks
to the brooklyn nets for james harden
and paul millsap porzingis is heading to
washington
we're going to talk about how these
trades affected futures markets in just
a minute but live
give us your immediate reactions
yeah i mean my immediate reaction right
off the bat is i'm not sure if james
harden is worth ben simmons seth curry
drummond and draft picks uh and that's
not to say that i don't love james
harden i do but that's a lot and i'm
also excited to see how this
simmons situation plays out in the nets
you know i don't really know how he's
been spending his off time uh hopefully
he's been in the gym working on his shot
and finding that aggression because he's
joining a team in the nets that plays
pretty aggressive and competitive so
hopefully it's a good fit for him over
there and finally my thought is i cannot
wait to watch harden and embiid i think
that's a dynamic duo they both play very
similar style basketball to me just that
hustle
that leadership they have with you know
i'm not just gonna tell you what to do
i'm gonna show you how to do it type of
energy so i'm excited to see what they
do it's it's gonna be exciting stuff
trades always excite me but um you know
it'll be interesting to see how it plays
out
it's gonna be very interesting a lot of
questions in the air but those questions
will be answered in the second half of
this nba season we've got some trades of
our own here liv we got some trades of
our own
yeah to make
around here
you give us comments we'll give you guys
hoodies jerseys locks
we need gifts though we need emojis
but most importantly we need
winners only please
we're we're still getting there liv we
practiced it
we're still getting there and that's
that's okay that's okay i'm going to
accept that i am going to accept that
but first right now it's time to give
away a jersey i'm in the bleacher report
app looking up the comments uh i see
maxwell rexel in here he's uh he says
over tonight for yana shout out to you
maxwell russell okay i'm i also see jay
lopez nine j lopez nine
uh he says honestly bro they've been
dominating
i don't know what he's talking about but
i wanted to give him a hood you know
what wha wha why not oh he's having a
conversation within the comments live
that's what's going down too we're
having the conversation within the
comments and yeah so therefore i'll give
you a hoodie i'll give you a jersey bro
you're having you're filling up our
comments giving out good takes having
conversations within our comments you're
walking away with a hoodie uh
actually a jersey now let's talk about
how the hardened simmons trait affects
the futures live let's take a look at
the odds to win the east live do you
think philly should be favorite
over the nets now
yeah i personally think so um i think
that one of the net's biggest downfalls
this entire season has been their
chemistry or lack thereof i mean you've
got katie who's been battling injuries
it seems james harden is the only
consistent person that's been on the
court throughout the season and he's
leaving now kyrie can't play in every
game he's in he's out uh the chemistry
has been the biggest struggle for this
next team and i'm not sure ben simmons
or seth curry or drummond is going to be
able to fix that i think james harden
like i said being the most consistent
player on this nets team
is is gone so i'm interested to see how
this chemistry works with the nets i'm
not sold on them i'm really not i worry
about the chemistry for them whereas the
76ers they've already got that
established chemistry they're winning
games and embiid just needs
he needs a buddy he needs a buddy to
help him win and that's gonna be james
harden so i actually like the 76ers a
lot better in this trade spot than i do
the nets but i think it's time to put a
little bit more respect on this bucks
team in the east now i think they're a
team that's been established with that
chemistry they've got a lot of strong
players and deep rosters so
it kind of makes me wonder if the bucks
are now sitting in a really nice spot
with all these different things changing
for these two teams the bucks might be
in a good a good position here
liv is saying put some respect
on those milwaukee bucks but now now
let's talk championship let's talk
championship live are you thinking
anything differently about
finals futures
yeah i mean like i said the bucks i
think there's there can be a little bit
more respect for them coming out of the
east um in terms of the east though i
think you know yeah like besides the
bucks i i i don't really have any
concerns uh the west i think kind of
stays the same you've got a golden state
warriors team that wants healthy i think
it's to be right back where they were
when draymond was on the court the suns
are obviously playing very well so it
really affects the east the most i still
feel good about where the west is
sitting so
just a little more respect on the bucks
and then we'll ride with the warriors
yeah yeah i like what you said their
ride with the warriors that's where i'm
definitely betting that's definitely
where i'm betting but also i i want you
guys to take a look
at the philadelphia 76ers plus eleven
hundred they just got james harden they
have joel and beat they got doc rivers
they have pieces they have pieces
to at least get to the finals and then
possibly play in the seven game matchup
to win it sitting at plus 1100
it's not bad to sprinkle some money on
that uh live
i'm in the comments right now though i'm
in the comments i got the handy dandy
phone today
uh i'm in the comments giving away
hoodies now four takes i got m bowling
in the comments my boy mike bowling
embiid is the troll goat he is the troll
ghost shot i took my man joel a beat for
the meme that he sent out today uh cj
from the bronx says don't sleep on his
heat
shout out to you cj you are walking away
with the hoodie let's not sleep on those
eat live uh
i also got snoopy 2153
snoopy says the warriors are not bad
value right now i agree oh colin frost
says doc rivers is an awful coach are
you kidding
you know what brother those are bad
vibes
you definitely have an opinion of yours
but those are bad vibes but you know we
do here we turn bad vibes into good
vibes so therefore you are walking away
with a hoodie live it's tnt
basketball thursday which means we are
betting the three by two the question is
will there be two three pointers in the
first three minutes of the game today we
are running it back liv the three by two
parlet
we got the brooklyn nets taking on the
washington wizards and the milwaukee
bucks taking on the phoenix suns
it's boosted live from plus 350 to plus
450 the question is will there be two or
more three-pointers made in the first
three minutes in each of these games get
in the comments and tell us if you are
riding with us live talk to us talk to
me talk to the people what are you
thinking
uh grab your sweat towels because this
is not gonna be an easy one okay we're
gonna be sweating we're gonna be
sweating it out okay but no
you know good cash out doesn't come
without a little sweat so just get used
to it but it's definitely going to be a
sweat uh you know this washington it's
washington it's the nets and it's also
the suns that rank bottom 10 in three
pointers made so
uh that obviously makes me a little bit
nervous they also rank bottom 10 and
three-pointers attempted so that makes
me double nervous however
this bucks team on the other hand ranks
top five in both threes attempted and
made so we are putting a lot of faith in
this buck's team and we're putting a lot
of faith in a guy named kyrie irving
okay because i do think kyrie is making
a statement tonight he is you know
without pardon and without kd um and
he's he's trying to show that this nets
team is going to be just fine we're
going to be just fine that's kind of the
vibe i think he's going to play with
tonight so i like we are we are putting
all of our
energy time and stress into kyrie irving
and the bucks in order to get it done
but it will be a sweat so just get
prepared
liv is keeping it a buck with everybody
in the comments saying it is going to be
a sweat
but we are absolutely
writing and putting our faith in the
books and kyrie irving i'm in the
comments right now liv i'm in the
comments
seeing what they're saying
i got k god 500 he gave us a gift it
says i believe in this team
he's believing in us live he's riding
with us k god 500 you are walking away
with the hoodie js23
says and you can trust the nets it's
talking to you liv saying you can trust
the nets shout out to you js23 you are
also riding uh walking away with the
hoodie uh we are all riding the three by
two parlay shout out to everybody that i
mentioned
once again y'all all walking away with
hoodies today in the app we asked you
how many points giannis is going to
score
the line is currently set at 29 and a
half live
let's take a look at some other player
point props live
do you think giannis will have over
or under 29 and a half points or
and are there any other props you like
on the board
yeah i mean i don't worry about yana
scoring over 29 and a half points up
against the sun's team right now they
give up uh 20 in the last seven they've
given up 24 points per game against
opposing power forwards and giannis is
not your average
power forward i think he's going to play
very well tonight
but i do i got to run it back y'all last
week i did tell you about mikel bridges
he ended up having himself a game i
cashed on over 13 and a half points and
i like him in this spot again tonight he
is facing a bucks team that allow in the
last seven has allowed the fifth most
points to opposing small forwards at
almost 25 per game his line is at 14 and
a half right now he's hit that over in
four of the last five so i love this
spot from mikel again tonight we cashed
on him last week we're gonna keep it
moving and i'm not gonna fade him until
i absolutely have to but i love where
he's at i love him facing this bucks
team tonight so give me mikel bridges
over 14 and a half points
liv is running it back live my mom
always said if it's not broke
don't fix it don't fix it hit last week
liv is running it back with my kell
bridges again i like that pic liv i kind
of like it more than my play but i'ma
tell you guys what i'm rocking with a
rocco and devin booker over
i think this one's gonna hit my man has
been absolutely on fire he's been
absolutely on fire but liv the last time
i rocked with a d book over he laid 11
points for me so hopefully the vibes
have changed hopefully the atmosphere is
going to give us you know some some good
vibes some good juju so we can get this
devin booker over tonight i'm in the
comments though i'm in the comments
giving away hoodies live uh and i see
be our beddings in the comments shout
out to b.r bedding in the comments i
also see uh official ronald go with all
the sun's players i guess he's saying go
with all the suns players overs i'm
guessing but yeah shout out to you
officially ronald you are walking away
with a hoodie oh parlay perkins has a
sunset gif i'll show you guys on on
camera there it is sunset gift
sunsets are the way to my heart not
gonna lie so therefore parlay perkins
you know you you've been a fan for a
while
you were walking away with the hoodie
live
let's talk major markets money lines
against the spreads and point totals for
tonight's game let's take a look at the
odds liv what are you seeing here
and what do you like
yeah i got i gotta fade the nets tonight
to be honest with you i'm i'm liking the
wizards at home minus one and a half to
cover that spread this nets team has
struggled without kd uh like i said
they've just got a lack of consistency
right now kyrie irving will be playing
tonight i imagine he will have a very
big night however he can't do it alone
patty mills to me is a little too
inconsistent for my liking so i don't
trust the nets in this spot they've
struggled without katie katie is not
back now they have no harden as well i
think the wizards are just in a better
spot here to get a dub at home and to
cover that one and a half point spread
so give me the wizards minus one and a
half
live is rocking with the wizards
i like that one liv but i want to talk
about the milwaukee bucks phoenix suns
game i
i just
this milwaukee team has been on a hot
streak on the west coast and i don't see
it changing i like the money line plus
money with the milwaukee bucks tonight
but let me get into these comments live
because that's what the people want they
want hoodies they want to get their
voice heard so let me get into the
comments and i see colin frost is back
in the comments he says nets losing
streak ends tonight shout out to you
colin frost you already won a hoodie but
trigger way is right above him with the
gif of kyrie irving so shout out to you
trigger way you are walking away with
the hoodie and he also told you liv uh
he also
i think he said i'm sorry
he said that the nets will win that's
fading you but that is okay you know
what we do to bad vibes here we give
them good vibes so we're moving on uh
uh booker over peever the duck is
agreeing with me so shout out to you pee
for the duck you are also walking away
with hoodie i got another take from here
larry segura says nets money line
because the players involved in the
trades won't play tonight for the wiz so
the comments are all over the place the
comments are all over the place but
shout out to everybody that commented
you are walking away with hoodie all
right we talked major markets now let's
talk player props it's time for lock or
not and i'm going to put up a prop and i
need everybody to get in the comments
and tell me whether it is a lock or it's
not let's get right to it first up is
kyrie irving to score 30 or more points
sitting at plus 150 live talk to me
do you like this one
or do you not
i like it i think it's a lock like i
said earlier uh he's kind of he's got to
be the main guy tonight for this nets
team and for everyone in the chat that's
fading me no beef no beef but we can
agree on this one if you think the nets
are winning that kyrie irving has to
have a big game for this next team to
win it's between pretty much him and
patty mills and like i said a little too
much inconsistency with patty mills for
me uh not to mention kyrie irving
without kd is averaging 25 points per
game this season and without hardin he's
averaging 24 points per game this season
so 30 plus what's five or six more
points he can do it
i think
not too much
is rocking with
kyrie irving uh i'ma hop in right now i
live i'm right there no actually i'm not
i'm not there with you liv i don't think
kyrie is going to get to 30.
uh
it's plus 150 for a reason so
i think i'm gonna lean the other way
uh
there's just been a lot of
inconsistencies going on in brooklyn and
i don't know if there's gonna if they're
gonna change tonight and i know kyrie
needs to score i know they need to win i
just don't think that he's gonna drop 30
tonight let's move on let's move on we
got patty mills lift patty mills to have
four or more three pointers made at plus
154 talk to me do you like this one or
do you not
i don't like i said too much
inconsistency here with patty mills for
me uh this wizards team gives up the
second fewest three pointers to their
opponent
i mean realistically he should hit this
because it's him and kyrie and that's
about it but i don't trust them enough
for four plus that's a lot of threes so
i'm gonna say it's not a lot there's a
lot of threes
that is a lot of threes live that's
steph curry territorian
i'm only betting on four or more threes
unless the man name is wardale stephen
curry that's the only time i'm putting
my money on four plus three-pointers so
uh i'm cool off this patty mills but let
me hop into the comments
let me hop into the comments and see
what they are saying uh i got m kent 93
says under on patty
steve irwin says under on paddy mills
three
uh
i silva 33 says live that cash is easily
i think he was talking about the uh
the first one that we did with the over
that you took uh with kyrie irving but
shout out to everybody that i mentioned
you are all walking away with hoodies
live
finally we have kyle kuzma
eight or more rebounds sitting at -166
talk to me liv do you like this one
do you not
[Music]
i do and uh surprisingly in the last
seven the nets have given up the third
fewest rebounds to opposing power
forwards at almost eight so right where
we need it to be but
that's
a little bit of a different story
tonight with so many people out no
hardin
hate you know kyrie and patty mills to
me aren't huge rebounders so i really
like this spot for kuzma i'm gonna rock
with it i think kuzma can get eight plus
so i'm gonna say it's a lot because he's
been rebounding very well this season so
i'm gonna rock with it yeah
i agree with you liv i'm rocking with it
i think it's minus 166 for a reason
the bookies i mean the casinos
the odds makers they know what's up uh
so i'm rocking with you as well let's go
to the comments though let's go to the
comments
and let's see what they are talking uh
i see
bucks moneyline i silva is saying they
see us bucks moneyline shout out to you
also reuben reuben x-a-m-l-o-l
cools is a lock
uh so he's rocking with you liv
and me and i got one more the comments
are jumping they are jumping lonnie hall
came monet he's going over
he's going over so yeah
kyle kuzma is going over shout out to
everybody that i mentioned you all are
walking away with hoodies all right it
is time to build the custom same game
parlay which you can ride with us on
fanduel we have hit two same game
parlays in a row last thursday we cast
in the sun's hulk game
it paid five to one
then on tuesday we hit another in the
lakers bucks game
almost 15 000 people rode with us taking
a payday of over
1.1 million dollars
tonight we are trying to hit three in a
row and we're looking at the bucks sons
game i need everybody to get in the
comments and tell me what they think
which legs or locks which legs or not
live
i'm ready to get right to it are you
ready
i'm ready let's do it
let's get right to it first off we're
starting off
with the point god himself chris paul to
record 12 or more assists
liv talk to me talk to the people do you
think this is a lock
or not
i love it i love it i think this leg is
great uh he's facing a bucks team
tonight that gives up the third most
assist to opposing point guard in the
last seven games so love this spot for
chris paul i also if i remember
correctly the last time that we had the
same game parlay we did have chris paul
in there for 12 plus assists and it hit
so it's got great energy behind it i
love it we know that he'll be
facilitating a lot tonight so i think
this leg is awesome
so liv is locking in the first leg of
the parlay chris paul
12 plus assist let's move on to the
second leg of the parlay devin booker to
score 25 or more points liv talk to me
talk to the people
do you like this leg of the parlay
well for the sake of your best bet i'm
gonna say absolutely because i think
you're right on the money with devin
booker tonight i think he has himself a
night uh he's facing a bucks team that
gives up quite a few points to opposing
shooting guards and and booker is that
guy you know if
if this is going to be a very
competitive game it's not going to be an
easy win for the suns by any means and
booker is the guy that you trust to get
points on the board and keep them in
this one so i like him to have a big
offensive night and keep doing what he's
been doing because he's been on fire so
yeah 25 plus i like it
yes liv likes one of my bets that i gave
you guys today uh so we're moving on we
are moving on chris middleton two plus
made
three pointers tonight liv talk to me do
you like this leg of the parlet
i do chris middleton has actually hit
this over in the last five consecutive
matchups like i said it's gonna be a
tough game for both teams these are two
strong teams that on both sides of the
ball here uh chris middleton is going to
be taking a lot of shots from the three
to keep the bucks in this one it's going
to be a very competitive match up so i
like this one as well
liz liking it she's liking this one all
right let's move
yes leg of the parlay my manianas
to record 10 or more rebounds live
you liked everything so far
do you like this last leg of the parlor
i do i think any time you've got um
giannis getting bored it's it's a good
bet and i know that uh this this sons
team has had ayton their big man who
does a lot of the rebounding in and out
a little bit um so
you know i
i think that giannis is in a good spot
here to get some rebounds
he seems to hit it pretty pretty often
and it doesn't seem i just i don't see
some i don't see anyone on this son's
team that can really guard giannis to
the point where he wouldn't
hit this
yeah i agree with you liv i don't i
don't see anybody on the sun's team that
can guard giannis myself so uh let's put
up the ticket so i could show you guys
the odds and the totals
for this parlay there it is if you put
up a hundred dollars
you're walking away with 400.35
yes there it is uh i'm gonna grate this
parlay usually i ask lib to grate the
parlay but we're gonna do it different
i'm gonna grate the parlay and i'm gonna
give it
a hey because i'm the one that told you
guys about the parlay why wouldn't i
give it a day but now i hope we hit this
parlay we are all riding you guys can we
ride with us at fanduel
i'm in the comments right now giving
away hoodies giving away jerseys
uh
i see del priet one deal pre yes this is
about the hit i love the good vibes this
is good energy
this parlay is easy money my trust is in
y'all give me a jersey greg deal freak
appreciate you you are walking away with
the hoodie i also see sports feed sport
speeds
he has a oh it's a lock and he's
unlocking the lock i think this is good
vibes meaning that we are going to win
our bet so shout out to you sports feats
you are walking away with the hoodie and
also i have to give away a jersey so i
see xavier
science xavier syed says easy
money to our parlay they are rocking
with us shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you all are walking away with
hoodies
hey
it's been fun
it's been fun all right thank you guys
for tapping into the group chat it's
definitely been fun presented by fendo
remember what you learned today the
three by two is a lot
get on fanduel and tell our br betting
same game parlay we're trying to hit
three in a row we need
good vibes we'll be back next thursday
with the special all-star game preview
giving out more hoodies more jerseys and
more locks if you want a hoodie today do
not worry do not be alarmed we will dm
you
alongside my co-host liv moods i'm greg
ivory
i'm leaving the group chat
peace
[Music]
you